graph QL a query language for AP is you
define a schema for your data then tell
graph QL how to fetch and supply that
schema and in doing so amazing things
might happen as we'll see in this video
and 9 ignition sequence start in today's
video you'll learn the fundamental
concepts of graph QL by interacting with
the public space X API if you're new
here like and subscribe and I'd like to
give a special thanks to Arjun ulam and
Shelley who is the mastermind behind
this video if you're looking for a graph
QL expert you can find his LinkedIn and
github in the description below let's
start by answering the question of what
is graph QL in the most basic sense it's
a language that allows your front-end
applications to communicate with your
back-end applications a rosetta stone if
you will a consistent way for your
front-end to request data from your
back-end despite any differences in the
underlying programming language for
example you're a mobile application
might need to request a sandwich from
your API it can make that request by
sending a graph QL query the query will
have the same shape that you expect to
receive back from the API as JSON so in
this case we expect a sandwich object
with bread ham and cheese on the server
graph QL also functions as a runtime for
executing queries the server defines
types for the data that's available
there and also resolvers to actually
fetch the data from a database or some
other data source now because everything
on the server is strongly typed we can
get some really amazing tooling with
graph QL to demonstrate this let's head
over to the graph QL Explorer for the
public space X API if you're the
consumer or using the API in your
front-end application you can do
introspection to the backend to see what
data is available there as you can see
here we have a whole bunch of different
checkboxes that represent different
queries we can make to the space X API
in the middle panel we already have an
example graph ul query ready to go now
go ahead and hit the play button to
execute the query and then you'll see on
the right side we get a JSON payload
returned from the server and what you'll
notice is that the properties on this
JSON object are identical to the way we
structured them in our graph QL query
and on top of that everything is
strongly typed if we hover over a field
in our graph QL query you can see that
it gives us a type there are several
built-in types like string integer etc
and the server can also define its own
custom types so when working with
QL as a front-end developer you'll
always know the exact shape of the data
that you're expecting back from the
server and speaking of that let's take a
second to look at the differences
between REST API s and graph QL api's
rest stands for representational state
transfer and it's the status quo for API
design that we've been following for the
last 20 years now let's say our
front-end application wants to make a
sandwich and rest we might make three
different requests one for bread ham and
cheese each request is mapped to its own
unique URL and each response from the
server would contain the full JSON
payload with everything that we need
like the full loaf of bread a full Pig
and a full wedge of cheese even though
our front-end application doesn't
necessarily need all that data we can
just filter it out in the front-end code
now in graph QL world things are quite a
bit different instead of having multiple
URL endpoints we just have a single
entry point into the API so it's the
actual query sent from the front end
that determines what the back end will
return it's not based on a URL or any
specific mapping like that in addition
the graph QL API will only return the
actual fields that were requested
instead of requesting ingredients one by
one we just get the full sandwich all
put together now let's say we also want
to add a side salad and a drink to this
query in graph QL it's a simple matter
of updating the query but in rest we
would likely have to make at least two
more requests to two different unique
URLs to get this data the beauty of
graph QL is that it simplifies the way
you request data from your front-end
code
so obviously graph QL is way better than
rest and you should never use rest ever
again right well it's really not that
simple
while graph QL provides a lot of
advantages there are some disadvantages
as well the biggest disadvantage in my
opinion is that there is some added
complexity up front you can build a
restful service with Express j/s with
like five lines of code but with graph
QL you have some additional dependencies
a type system and the benefits might not
be that substantial if you're a small
team or have a relatively simple API the
benefits of graph QL really kick in when
you have multiple developers working
with a large API that needs to map
together a whole bunch of different
back-end data sources in any case graph
QL is very fun to work with as a
developer so let's go ahead and play
around with some queries to space X
let's go ahead and delete the default
and then we'll make a query for all of
the rockets in space X click the box for
Rockets and then
you hover over rockets you'll notice
that it returns a query of an array of
rockets a rocket is a custom type
defined by the server and if we click on
it we can see all the different data
properties available there and then we
can simply click the checkboxes for the
properties that we want returned from
this query and what you'll also notice
is that queries can take arguments in
this case we can set a limit to a
specific number of rockets or we can
offset it if we're doing pagination so
now that we have a list of rockets let's
go ahead and copy one of the IDS and
make a request for an individual rocket
go ahead and click the rocket box and
you'll notice this query takes an ID as
its argument and simply select the
properties that you want to read on the
rocket object and that's really all
there is to it when it comes to fetching
data from a graph QL API but there are a
couple more advanced things that you
should know about you can reuse values
throughout your queries by using
variables which you'll see prefixed with
a dollar sign but sometimes you might
actually want to change the query
entirely based on the value of a
variable for example you can see we have
this glutton free variable so we might
not want to include bread if that option
is set to true so if the gluten-free
boolean is true then it will include
bread on this order but that's not
exactly right so let's go ahead and do
the exact opposite with the skip
directive to exclude bread if it's set
to true and it's also possible that your
graph QL schema has a certain property
that returns multiple types or a union
type for example our sandwich might come
with a side and that side might either
be french fries or a salad if it's a
salad if then we might want to return
the dressing field and if it's french
fries then we might want to return the
side field so as a front-end developer
graph QL gives you a lot of flexibility
for structuring your queries and then
it's up to your back-end developers to
write the code to resolve the queries
which tends to be the more difficult
part in addition to reading data by
making queries you might also want to
write data or modify data on the server
by using a mutation a mutation works
just like a query but it's a convention
that signals that some data will be
modified on the server so now that you
know the basics of graph QL I want to
show you how to put it to use in an
actual real-world front-end application
the most popular way to work with graph
QL from a front-end application is to
use the Apollo client it's essentially a
state management library that allows you
to write graph QL queries then see the
results automatically update
in your UI Apollo has integrations for
all the major JavaScript frameworks like
angular react view etc including vanilla
web components and also native platforms
like iOS and Android what I want to show
you over the next few minutes is a
practical example combining Apollo graph
QL and angular our goal is to create a
simple web app that will fetch the
recent launches from SpaceX and when we
click on a specific launch it will take
us to the details for that launch along
with some pictures now as I mentioned
earlier one of the big advantages of
graph QL is the awesome tooling that it
provides and when combined with
typescript it gets even better you'll
also learn how to convert your graph QL
API into a series of interfaces that you
can use directly in your front-end
application so when you combine angular
with graph QL you get end and type
safety providing an amazing developer
experience you can see here I'm in a
brand new angular app and the first
thing I want to do is install the Apollo
graph QL extension for vs code it
provides syntax highlighting and
everything else you need to work with
graph QL and vs code from there we'll go
to the root of the project and create a
new file called Apollo config KS this
will tell Apollo where to find our
back-end API which in this case should
point to the public space X API the next
step is to generate a couple of
components that we can use for the
screens in this app we have a ListView
that will show all the recent launches
from SpaceX and then also a detailed
view we can generate these components
with the angular CLI and we'll also set
the change detection to on push which is
just a little performance optimization
that we can use here because with Apollo
and graph QL the only thing that we
actually need to do is subscribe to
observables for our data so we don't
need to use angular's built-in change
detection the next thing we'll do is
jump into the app routing module and set
up routes for these actual components
we'll set the route route to our launch
list component that's the default route
that user lands on then if they click on
one of the launch cards it will take
them to a URL parameter with that ID and
show additional details about that
specific launch that takes care of our
routing configuration now let's go into
the app component and delete all of the
boilerplate code that comes with a
default angular app just make sure to
leave the router outlet and now we're
ready to write our first graph QL query
and the reason I want to do this first
is because as you'll see in a minute
here we can use the query to
automatically generate
angular services interfaces and
basically everything else we need to
work with our back-end data go into the
launch list component and create a new
file called launch list graph QL now
unlike the interactive editor we'll
start out our query by writing the query
keyword and then we can give that a name
called past launches list and we'll have
it take a parameter called limit which
will take an integer argument and the
exclamation mark after the type makes it
required then inside the query we'll
write some graph QL code just like we
did earlier in the video
we'll make a reference to the launches
past query that's provided by SpaceX and
then we'll pass in our limit argument
from there we'll add the actual fields
that we want for each individual launch
object like the idea mission name links
to some images and so on so this defines
all the data that we want to show in our
launch list component and now we'll move
over to our launch details component and
do the same thing by creating a launch
details graph QL file one thing you'll
notice on this query is that we have a
required type of ID the ID type works
just like a string except that it
signals that it's a unique value and we
can pass that ID to the launch query in
graph QL and then filter by the fields
that we actually want from the API so
now that we have our graph QL queries in
place we can generate a whole bunch of
code automatically the first thing we'll
need to do is integrate Apollo into this
project so head over to the command line
and run ng add Apollo angular this
command will install our Apollo
dependencies and also create a graph QL
module in the app directory go ahead and
open up that file and tell it where to
find the graph QL API by modifying this
URI variable so that takes care of the
setup for Apollo but we want to generate
a lot of our code automatically as
opposed to writing it manually
the tool that can help us do that is the
graph QL code generator this is a really
awesome tool that you can use on both
the backend and front-end to look at
your graph QL schema and then
automatically generate typescript
interfaces and in our case angular
services that can fetch the data from
the backend we have this big long
install command and you can copy and
paste that from the lesson repo once
those are installed we'll create a code
gen Yama file in the root of the project
this simply tells the code generator
where to find our graph QL files and
what to generate once it finds them and
now that we have that configuration in
place we just need a commander
that will actually run the generator we
can do that by going into the
package.json and going into these
scripts will create a new command called
cogent that runs the generator then we
can open up the terminal and run that
command and you'll see it generates a
new directory called services with a
service that we can use to fetch data
from the graph QL API now the cool thing
about the code generator is that it
looked at the actual schema of the
SpaceX API and also our local graph QL
queries and combine the two together so
we now have an angular service that has
all the interfaces from the SpaceX API
and also methods to fetch the data that
we actually want based on our own local
graph QL queries that was quite a bit of
configuration to get started but now
that we have that done we really only
have to focus on writing components and
writing graph QL queries now let's go
ahead and finish things up by writing
the components for the user interface to
make things look nice I'll go ahead and
add angular material to this project by
running ng ad at angular material and
then in the app component I'll import
the material card module from there I'm
going to head over to the launch list
component type script and the first
thing I'll do is inject the past
launches service in the constructor
remember this service was automatically
generated by the code generator the
service is able to fetch the past
launches from SpaceX by using the fetch
method and then we can pass in a limit
argument and set it to 30 the response
is going to have some additional data
that we don't really need so what we'll
do is pipe in the map operator and then
we'll just map the response down to the
actual data that we want to show in the
UI which in this case will be the
response data launches past now if we go
into the template we can unwrap the past
launches observable by using the async
pipe and then we'll set the result as a
template variable called past launches
the past launches will be an array of
launch objects so we can simply loop
over them using the ng for directive and
angular that will give us a material
card for each individual launch and then
we can add a router link that will point
to that specific launch ID so when the
user clicks on a card it will route them
to the launch details component and then
everything after that is pretty standard
angular templating will display a
material cart header with an image and
then a title and a subtitle at this
point you should be able to run ng serve
from the terminal and then open up local
4,200 and see a list of launches from
the SpaceX API now at this point when
you click on an actual item it will take
you to the launch details component but
we haven't actually built that one out
yet so let's go ahead and do that now go
ahead and open up the launch details
component type script and then we'll
import activated route from angular
router and also our launch details graph
QL service and then we'll go ahead and
inject those and the constructor the
reason we need activated route is
because our graph QL query takes an ID
as its argument and we get that ID from
the URL in the browser angular provides
all of the URL parameters as an
observable which we can access on the
activated route per a map when we have
that observable we want to switch to an
observable of the actual data from graph
QL that's a perfect use case for the
rxjs switch map operator in other words
once we have the ID parameter from the
URL we'll go ahead and switch to another
observable which in this case is the
launch detail service fetch of that
specific ID and then like we did in the
previous example we'll go ahead and map
the response down just to the raw data
because we don't need any of the
additional metadata that comes back with
the response and then also like we did
in the previous example we'll unwrap the
observable at the top of the file by
using the async pipe and then we'll set
a template variable as launch details
and from there we simply add some HTML
for the UI and interpolate the values
that we want to show to the user and
keep in mind I am using a few custom CSS
Styles here you can find those in the
full lesson repo and if we go back to
our app you'll notice that when we click
on a launch it will show the actual
launch details and some additional
photos in the detail page
congratulations you now have a full
stack Apollo graph QL powered angular
app now if you want some extra credit
I'd recommend going to the full lesson
repo give it a star and check out the
extra credit section at the very end
it'll show you how to build an angular
pipe that will format the actual dates
of the launches in relative time for
example it will say a launch occurred 10
seconds ago yesterday 5 days ago and so
on I'm gonna go ahead and wrap things up
there if this video helped you please
like and subscribe and consider becoming
a pro member at fire ship IO to get
access to even more
thanks for watching and I will talk to
you soon five four three two one zero
all engine running
[Music]